[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro part je
vous présenter les invités d'antan
quelques instants mais j'aurais d'abord
qu'on regarde peut-être d'une bande
annoncele de joker parce que vous allez
voir que ça a un rapport avec ce dont
nous allons parler
[Musique]
nous avons une grosse farce
l'espace
[Musique]
pour moi
elle
avec eux
[Musique]
astori
la queue
[Musique]
c'est devenu le croire
voilà c'est le film de todd phillips
avec joaquin phoenix alors qu'elle est
un peu la naissance comme ça donne un
tueur en série dont une personne un peu
banale qui devient un tueur en série
on a des cas comme ça on a vu à bayonne
par exemple ce type de 84 ans à dix mais
voilà puis les gens parce qu'ils vont à
la mosquée et c'est vrai qu'on est dans
une on a l'impression comme ça qu'on est
un je vous ai pas présenté je vous
présentais d'avoir un bernard delattre
ou bochum
bonjour vous êtes journaliste écrivain
vous avez été une autre aujourd'hui
c'est une nouvelle de versailles mais ce
sont aussi écrivain et vous vous
organiser un salon du livre à l encourus
le 24 novembre
c'est la troisième édition ça s'est fait
régler les amis du passé d'elancourt
présidée par jean flattot alors les amis
du passé depuis 30 ans s'occupe d'une
vie ont fait une vigne un peu
pédagogique à la ferme du buisson
et puis on s'est dit il faudrait faire
une manifestation et pourquoi pas un
salon du livre comme j'ai rappelé
l'expérience avec rambouillet qui existe
depuis onze ans je suis l'association
arts et lettres de ruines nazies on va
faire un salon du ils ont dit ok et ça a
marché quoi bein c'est bien et c'est
quand ben c'est le dimanche 24 novembre
sous la présidence d'honneur de patrice
franceschi
un goncourt de la nouvelle 2004 dont on
parle beaucoup actuellement pour son
combat pour aider les kurdes
il est partout il se bat depuis sept ans
avec eux n'hésitent pas à prendre le
fusil s'il faut très bon journaliste et
écrivain nicolas sanhes jour bonjour
sept sculpteurs vous êtes artiste
sculpteur notamment aux propos et vous
est notamment spécialisée de sculptures
monumentales qu'on peut voir dans les
villes on en voit notamment à trappes
meyer aussi depuis peu a frappé les
faire il s'était fait aussi dans celle
de strasbourg
oui
un peu partout ddd donc des sculptures
qui sont à la fois des oeuvres d'art
évidemment mais qui habille aussi une
ville afin qu'ils ont un sens dans le
dans l'urbanisme
j'habite une ville en ruines j'habitais
nuit voilà c'est bien on vient à l'idée
qu'ils transforment l'espace dans une
ville qui re créer du du sens en tout
cas pour les pour se retrouver qui
sacralise heures les espaces qui
transforme la bulle et qui j'espère
l'embellie on a parlé tout à l'heure et
puis on parlera aussi peut-être de la
place de l'artiste dans une société qui
peut être un peu difficile je ressens de
la joie dit bonjour bonjour eva vous
êtes éditeur dont des auteurs qui vont
saluer le retour peut-être des scans non
alors non et des escales oui non mais
j'ai scanné des îles et dans le nord est
voilà très occupée par la sortie du
livre qui sort dans c'est votre dernière
publication qui revient jours voilà
c'est une très belle enfin belle c'est
pas le mont darwin est une horrible
histoire de 4-2-4 barbares qui qui
enlèvent des jeunes femmes pour leur
faire des véritable misère c'était assez
dur mais un trio de policiers qu'on a
déjà vu dans un précédent roman qui
revient et qui qui luttent justement
contre c'est contre ces barbares et ça
décrit très bien surtout le tout cette
région du nord qui est par moments un
peu un peu rude
un bus man point de vue mais avec des
gens qui sont extrêmement les barbares
mise à part notamment sympathique
extrêmement chaleureux extrêmement voilà
donc ce roman montre bien les dc2 côté
et supercars prendra qu'une envie c'est
de se précipiter dans le nord mais enfin
c'est beau mais c'est magnifique
oui c'est quelquefois un peu
un peu triste un peu triste mais face
non vous avez travaillé en ont assez du
week-end à boulogne-sur-mer
valenciennes non mais c'est vrai que
quand on connaît pas la date de
valenciennes moi j étais ses effets
bénéfiques
le stade de football de la vie est
ailleurs accueilli à la salle acl louvre
ya louvre il fait beau qui fait beaucoup
pour la pour la région la ville de lens
et peut-être pas la plus la plus belle
le stade le stade est magnifique et
l'ambiance mais c'est surtout le public
fabuleux stade en lui même
oui aujourd'hui avec cette chanson là
que tout le monde entonne faut qu'on y'a
35 écoles qui entonnent les corons et
tout ça se voit qu'on avait les clés
voilà c'est vrai que c'est aussi
volailles et des belles régions tout à
fait dans le groupe alors je reviens sur
ce que je disais un petit peu en début
d'été visions on avait vu donc cette von
arx de tokai et c'est vrai que je
tombais sur une déclaration de françois
fillon mais qui disait notre
responsabilité c'est de faire vivre les
gens ensemble dans la compréhension
mutuelle à la définition donnée de la
politique ou du politique et on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
une société où les gens n'ont pas
forcément plus forcément reid de vivre
ensemble que les positions sur
deviennent de plus en plus extrémistes
que avoir disco modéré si on a dit ce
qu'on me dit on l'entend plus et que
peut-être le vivre ensemble et aux
crises non moi je suis pas tellement
d'accord avec votre habibi ou non bah
dis donc que le fait que le que la
définition de politiques ça doit du tout
est de faire vivre les gens là dessus de
tout à fait raison mais je pense je
pense pas qu'ils aient une véritable
crise
ça c'est parce que
à chaque fois évidemment ont tourné
autour du pot parce que en fait quel est
le problème surtout en ce moment
d'actualité pas le vivre ensemble entre
les bouddhistes et dès maintenant c'est
on a il ya les sondages le prouvent il
ya une certain certains antagonismes
avec certaines personnes d'origine
enfin de confession musulmane et puis
des gens qui ne sont pas qu'il y voilà
est ce que tout le monde ne devrait pas
vivre comme on vit nous est pas là si on
arrive c'est plutôt eu 90 % de
population a plutôt envie que tout le
monde vive ensemble correctement mais
pas avec de nouvelles vagues de
nouvelles coutumes et pas de nouvelles
habitudes je pense que ça ne devait pas
l'impression que les positions sont en
train de devenir extremis françois
lenglet la spécialiste de l'économie il
dit actuellement il ya là le croisement
de deux cours de celle de la montée du
populisme et celle des des problèmes de
des finances et de la bourse alors il ya
une théorie c'est que toutes les années
en 9
tout va basculer sur loing michel dont
les années qui finissent en 1789 les
neuf ans pourra faire 1914 19h19 la
crise de l'histoire 29 l'écart côte
derrière de 39 1989 la chute du mur du
bernard est assez positif était une fin
de cycle positif comme daury notre ami
et comme 69 année érotique
pas mal alors c'est une théorie monde de
fin de cycle où les gens veulent
repartir à zéro et çà et là il ya comme
cette montée des populismes que griller
la montée des populismes et yann c'est
l'impression donnée on a vu comment rené
ce débat sur le voile notamment en fin
de possession on peut avoir des
désaccords au poids lourds mode contre
on pourra en discuter de manière un peu
des passionnés non l'acte que ce soit
non vous trouvez pas voilà mais je pense
que c'est le signe de manque de
confiance je pense nous voulons losc
homme de confiance on est optimiste dans
la vie s'est ouvert à ses généreux donc
on a tout à fait le plaisir de
rencontrer personne différente qu'en
tout cas c'est la conception que j'ai
deux mois de l'ouverture et d'échangés
ce que j'avais déjà fait vrai que c'est
de ce que vous appelez vivante qui met
l'accent sur le côté centrale de chaque
individu égoïste pour peut-être des
réseaux aux comptes peut expliquer sur
les causes de l'économie qui peut être
pas oui mais peut-être 10h30 politique
enfin le voit bien qu'il ya quand même
des groupes étaient des gens qui ont
tendance à stigmatiser certaines
catégories de population vous avez
travaillé par exemple un train pour
venir tout à l'air est une ville où il
ya des communautés différentes riquiqui
qui coexistent voix seulement je trouve
que trapattoni l'hébergement sympa ouais
c'est plutôt ça se passe plutôt bien ça
se passe très très bien
les gens sont agréables en tout cas ce
que j'ai pu rencontrer lorsque j'emmène
ma sculpture où je travaille sur le
projet ont été très généreux très ouvert
aux 100 ch et le souvenir de belles
rencontres les personnes avec une femme
qui était voilée qui était très élégante
et qui était heureuse de voir une
sculpture contemporaine devant chez elle
donc il faut pas qu'on soit on a le plus
souvent ça être
influencé mais faisons nous une propre
idée de ce que nous vivons est ce que
nous voyons presque aussi on peut aussi
on peut contre le port du voile tout en
reconnaissant que toutes les femmes
voilées sont pas être élégante
intelligente exercent il n'y a pas de
jugement de valeur sur la fin mais il ya
un jugement sur le sur le fait de porter
ou non un voile et je pense que va être
sur le vivre ensemble
quand même beaucoup de gens qui la
vivent ensemble sans voile et que dès
qu'on a un discours qui est belle non
justement avez-vous n'est pas du voile
voulait pas qu'on vive ensemble voulait
monter les gens les uns contre les
autres
non c'est pas assez pas simplement qu'
on peut avoir envie de dire bah on
vivait très bien je sais pas je vous
défie même de trouver à trappes il ya 30
ans une femme voilée bon il n'y en avait
pas bon alors est ce qu'on vivait moins
bien à trappes ya 30 ans n'ont pas et
c'est ça aussi l'aspiration d'une partie
de la population qui est de dire ben
voilà il ya trente ans c'était bien il y
avait pas il y avait des musulmans des
immigrés étaient déjà arrivés il y avait
aucun problème et le problème
il vient aussi de de sa de cette espèce
de changement de volonté plus ou moins
avouée de dire on va changer les
habitudes et des français ben voilà
peut-être que les français tous les
sondages le pohon pas forcément envie de
changer 72 comment ils sont français
aussi non mais je me renseigne non
musulmans
il a mal à bien de sortir aller où il
dit qu'en 21ème c'est qu'on devrait
sortir de ces histoires de religion
chercher autre chose
il lui dit faudrait faire l'art en
lui-même le dalaï lama dit ça il faut
faire la religion de la compassion être
retrouvé la confiance qui s'est
installée à redouter est-ce que c'est
justement ce pas un problème le poids
des religions à mussidan saab dans une
société où on aurait pu penser qu'elle
allait décliner quand même non 6 oui
mais avec un poids plume afin
d'accueillir les physiciens des choses
dans une convention si l'histoire
donc honnêtement pas grand mais il ya
toujours des mouvements comme ça dans
les sociétés qui font que par moments il
souhaitait ne pas avoir des fortes les
bennes et pas en nombre bien la
philosophie de charles de gaulle c'est
dans le livre de gérard bardy charles
catholique était très croyant mais il ne
le montrait jamais il disait que les
croyances religieuses ça doit rester à
l'aller mais même les dimanches mine
quand il y avait un photographe et un
cameraman il n'allait pas commis ne
voulait jamais il n'y a aucune photo de
lui parce qu'on se plaît ici dans le
domaine privé
je pense que c'est une bonne chose
chacun de garder ses croyances sans lui
on n'a pas à les exhiber des siennes
aloi dans le domaine public a pas et
sont revenus vers ça et même
de gaulle d'après jean avoir dit qu'il
avait fait une petite chapelle alizés
peu dur ça où il y avait un aumônier qui
faisait faire la messe mais dès qu'il
est parti bon cette chapelle a été
c'était fini quoi mais lui quand il y
avait un photographe une caméra il
n'allait pas comme une île bouleversée
une conception très classique de la
laïcité
et c'est vrai que les réseaux derniers
sondages c'est pas drôle d'idée
dimanche qui montre que les français
sont très inquiet des atteintes à la
laïcité c'est l'art qui est important
dans notre pays c'est tous les jours
donc c'est effectivement entre gens de
bonne compagnie tout un désaccord redire
c'est effectivement la région s'apprête
personnel on n'a absolument rien contre
on croit on croit pas chacun est libre
de faire ce qu'il veut mais il n'y a pas
à le montrer de façon ostensible et
presque employés en boucle tout le monde
et ps mais colonisatrice il n'y a pas de
raison des dettes la voir des des tonnes
de gens pour dire voilà regarder une
autre religion comme elle est belle non
et on en revient avec la question de
base c'est les sorties scolaires c'est
vrai que vient ce qu'on a envie que des
enfants le soin soit accompagnée par
quelqu'un qui montrent sensiblement une
religion ou plutôt qu'une autre
alors cessez de la vraie question est la
sgp et une fois qu'on a dit ça c'est ça
veut pas dire qu'on a envie que les gens
soient montés les uns contre les autres
on a justement en disant s'il n'y avait
pas thing religieux du tout les gens ce
ne serait pas monter les uns contre les
autres on pourrait tous autour de cette
table croire chacun d'un dieu différent
il ya pas de problème de dire on n'en
parlerait si on envie d'en parler en
petit comité pas la télévision c'est que
c'est que il ya des comme ça avec des
opinions différentes et heureusement
c'est ça la démocratie
on a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
l'opinion de l'autre n'est plus tolérée
si on a une opinion non tolérance qui
monte quoi lutter contre ça s'est
illustré de cheveux différence entre
opinions et croyances
le débat était revivre mais est ce que
vous pensez pas dire que le le fait le
président de chaîne d'info continue qui
a changé considérablement la façon de
faire de la politique par exemple et
changent aussi notre façon de voir les
opinions se dire que tous les jours il
ya des débats qui sont organisées avec
des pour des contres avec évidemment
comme il faut faire parler de soi on
prend plutôt d entre deux positions
extrêmes où que dès que des positions
plutôt nuancé non
j'entendais un présentateur de teulet il
désespéré parce qu'il trouvait pas une
femme avec à voile et à la radio
défendre un tout petit peu les chaînes
d'info parce que tout le monde les
attaques m'ont dit oui veut le faire le
buzz et faire mais il ya quand même
quasiment que sur les chaînes d'info que
par exemple en cas de grève de la sncf
on va interviewer des usagers qui sont
contre les grévistes et des usagers qui
soutiennent les grévistes alors que sur
les grandes chaînes
non non nous on continue on voit ça on
le voit on ne voit l'écouté france inter
il ya jamais quelqu'un à chaque fois
qu'on interroge c'est toujours des gens
qui adorent soutient les grévistes est
clair il n'y a jamais un usager jamais
jamais jamais un nom je vous défie d'en
trouver un ce n'est que sur les chaînes
d'info qui avait deux sons de cloche là
je veux dire de service public
on est tous entonnent tu on ne trouve
que des gens qui soutiennent les gilets
jaunes qui soutiennent les grévistes qui
souhaitait de toute revendication est la
réchauffer le public là bas on a trouvé
en interview et les gens alors après
vous achetez le journal sondages
indiquent absolument l' inverse
mais voilà donc les chaînes d'info au
moins de temps en temps elles font la
part des choses et puis voilà on a vu
ces gens là on a vu ces gens là et on
voit les deux donc c'est c'est passing
la date et je pense qu'il nous manque on
est trop dans les stands à plus de dix
ans donc c'est ça qui est c'est ça qui
la cause ou si nous on a perdu 7
regardez aux critiques de l'instant et
du temps qui est en train de souder coup
laissé couler même s'il est très présent
c'est vraiment une thématique et parce
qu'on est tous immédiatement
absolument on a raconté son nez et on
est sûr mais d'avoir une position celle
ci j'ai aussi alors qu'on pourrait très
bien pourrait très bien dire je sais pas
un jour sais rien je verrai plus si on
est le pouvoir non plus d'ailleurs pas
le droit quand il conduit une mort de
quelque chose on l'avait vu quand on
continue la l'attentât la préfecture de
police vers le mythe de l'intérêt à tous
et à une conférence de presse immédiate
alors qu'il ne sait rien de ce qui s'est
passé ne connais rien du type en
question
donc il dit ddd chose qui vaut ce
démenti quelques quelques heures plus
tard parce qu'il faut tout de suite
donné un peu comme on donnerait à manger
comme hélas sont obliger les hommes
politiques et le monde du gouvernement
de réagir et de sueur rsa parce que côté
ne réagissent pas à ce moment
veut pas nous dire ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent qu'est-ce qui
brûlent à côté de rouen a salué la bonne
position mais ça c'est du médiateur
extrêmement difficile le raccourci le
monde
on avait une belle planète crampes de
granby
d'abord parce qu'on sait tous ce qui se
passe parce qu'il est surveillé et dans
l'espace et dans le temps ça sera aussi
silva qu al le monde et avait l'air
tellement qu'ils seront tous étaient
très divers il ya une manifestation de
cette sylviane agacinski même chose
quand la ville africaine d'une
philosophe ci-contre la gpa mais ça fait
très longtemps enfin le considère que ça
fait un marché qui n'est pas digne pour
les pour les femmes qui s'y prêtent
elle devait faire une conférence de
presse à l'université une conférence de
presse une conférence à l'université
la conférence a été interdite sous
pression de mouvements lgbt pour la
corse que l'université quand même en
page des gens de s'exprimer
là on touche le fond enfin je vais on ne
peut pas imaginer que vous rencontrer
mais qui ne peut pas imaginer pire quoi
je veux dire
c'est extrêmement intelligente on peut
les cultiver les argumenter on peut tout
à fait et c'était l'idée c'est qu'il
s'agissait d' une des pionnières de vin
et d'aidé de la parité devenir un homme
parce que continue la parité
hommes-femmes
il y avait toujours des gens disaient
oui mais pourquoi pourquoi pas justement
des papas des hommes et des femmes si
des musulmans des juifs dévoile enfin
pourquoi on fait pas un nouveau pas elle
disait bien tonné le monde et pas des
visiteurs 50 % d'hommes 5% de femmes
puis le reste c'est autre chose c'est
une femme inculpée dit extrêmement
agréable de discuter les des arguments
on peut bien évidemment être ce n'est
pas opposé à sa position mais elles
l'acceptent on peut discuter c'est quand
même l'essence même de la discussion du
débat et puis de la faculté enfin ce n
est qu une faculté qu avec un patron
d'une faculté accepter sous la halle est
la pression de groupuscules fascistes ya
pas d'autres termes c'est du fascisme à
la petite semaine c'est à dire que ça
nous plaît pas que mon vieux convient de
dire qu'on est contre la gpa dont on
interdit le truc sinon on peut on va se
fâcher on va tout casser mais où va-t-on
c'est totalement mais souvent d'un
visage déjà interdite nicolas ii de
parole non non non non il ya des
réactions parfois vives contre la montre
les artistes n'est pas jusqu'à présent
je n'avais pas mais moi je ne travaille
que tu pas que patrie
polémique m'a dit qu'on ne comprennent
pas c'est une chose mais pas dans la
polémique
bien qu'à bien que véhicules et des
oeuvres qu'il faut polémique oui à 12
autres fonds privés que mes instructions
de quand on n'a pas la langue le bon cru
pour comprendre ce qui est une affaire
d'ars forcément une forme un peu
abstrait tout mais là c'est là c'est
quand même une manifestation
d'intolérance dans une université à sens
unique et qui est quand même le lieu où
le lieu du débat où devrait y avoir que
des changes s'est passé début on va
rejoindre ce qui se passe aux etats unis
parce qu'on colle toujours à la roue des
américains avec dix ou vingt ans de
retard
mais là le laps de temps se serait assis
dans les facultés états unis il ya des
profs qui n'ont plus droit d'enseigner
parce qu'ils sont pas d'un dock dans la
droite ligne de la pensée mainstream et
on leur dit ah bah non là vous allez
parler ça annonce cette hauteur là il
faut pas en parler
on a brûlé des livres aux états unis et
ça va les rendre la tâche un peu ça mais
ça va venir en france et le dire en
france parce que ce même groupuscule qui
interdit à cette conférence autour de la
deux tours à gpa bas dir est mais on a
listé ce qu'ils avaient dans la
bibliothèque
il ya des tas d'auteur qui sont pas du
tout pro lgbt et ses réalisations il est
environ l'aide du truc parce que nous on
parlera de parler n'ont pas le droit
d'écrire et c'est la fin de tout on s'en
rapproche
ça c'est en juin cnw deux heures sur les
traiter de l'information c'est à dire
que des groupes comme ça en jouant avec
la limite de thé de l'information dans
les réseaux on est dans une autre façon
de penser de regarder un problème simple
il ya est un autre débat comme ça qui
était cassé
un peu symptomatiques et c'est
intéressant c'est divin proposition de
loi pour interdire les corridas aux
mineurs et puis il ya un certain nombre
de personnalités dont pierre arditi
notamment qui ont signé une pétition
pour dire mais on comprend tout à fait
que les gens n'y aille pas ne va y aller
et personne ne les oblige à y aller mais
n'interdisez pas d'interdits et pas de
spectacles dont ils disent après on peut
juger que c'est vrai ou pas vrai que
c'est un c'est une approche s'apparente
à de l'art vous aurez signé des
pétitions comme arditi ou ça c'est comme
moi je les gens qui sont contre la
corrida moi je leur conseille d'aller
voir un abattoir
moi je veux dire porterez les
appréciations c'est quand même bien
qu'on vous voit un abattoir
on mange tous de la viande en face aux
flux de dégâts qu'on voit l'abattoir on
se dit finalement le corridor acceptable
parce que vous visez pas oui enfin ça
parce que ça fait pour les volets pour
les parties de l'alaric là c'est pas ce
qui se passe dans les abattoirs et ça
fait réfléchir
mais c'est vrai tout le monde il faut y
aller depuis hier les prix c'est sûr on
aura encore une fois avalée dire peu
importe ce qu'on pense de l'accord
on a faim tout à fait enfin j'espère on
va encore avoir le droit en france
d'avoir une opinion divergente de de la
majorité à dire que c'est un souhait
arditi lancé nuisent de la culture il ya
jean reno il ya de yafo des manèges à la
40 personnes qui sont tout sauf des
abrutis et qui qui met une idée en
disant n'interdisait pas ça ok on prédit
cité une tradition qui est d'ailleurs
très très circoncise dents
le sud dans certaines villes et il y ait
beaucoup d'oeuvres baril picasso
notamment littérature et bien oui il ya
des signes et surtout jean qui était
demandé que le fait qu'on ait le droit
d'avoir un avis différent ils ont le
droit de dire vive la corrida c'est on
va pas les tuer ce qu'ils puissent
continuer à parler on a le droit de
s'exprimer
un enfant c'est ça c'est vrai que le
démentiel dans une époque de changement
je parlais des abattoirs de relations
entre les hommes et les animaux c'est à
dire que d'entendre les animaux étaient
considérés comme des meubles d'ailleurs
même juridiquement le statut a changé
c'est vrai que c'est en train de se
rendre à une regard sur la souffrance à
l'humain l'animal qu'ils sont plus forts
que c'est trop loin aussi une région
d'élevage charlet vu que au milieu des
vaches du charolais tout ça il ya la
même chose dans salers tout ça mais que
seraient les paysages français savent
estivale dvd ultra vegan 10 fours à
lasser les vaches dehors elle est que
avec celle vont faire aller je crois
qu'il ya depuis les temps les plus
anciens mais là la préhistoire y ait un
deal secret entre les hommes et les
animaux
l'élévation le d'élevage et sont soignés
les hommes les aides avaient les ailes
sont soignés nourris pendant un certain
nombre d'années qu'à un moment elle
passe à la casserole mais lui m'a aussi
à nous on va passer à la question êtes
vous fait parler d'eux cette cause là
c'est leur gay des cimes du moment où la
secret à la corde mais s'il ya plus
d'élevage mais les vaches n'existent
plus ils ont une belle vision et il ya
plus de corridas il y aura plus leur as
des taureaux 16 mois la deuxième maladie
disparaît c'est comme les vaches de
charolais bchl villegats on y voir plus
de cheval
quant à bout le fait de manger ce soir
mais il ya je crois dit cette race qui
disparaîtraient en rampant au moins de
10 ans en europe dix sept races de
chevaux qui disparaîtront parce que les
boucheries chevalines disparaît oui mais
rien n'en revient encore dans beaucoup
de supermarchés
il ya des petits rayons ouais petit ou
entourent encore la viande de chat mais
si on arrête de consommer du fal et ben
oui c'est les animaux existe des races
de chevaux qui ne seront plus faut-il
qu'ils voient ce que l'économie de
beaucoup de gens qui utilisent d'aider
des chevaux de trait etc
elle se justifie parce que le cheval
travail concerne d'année et qu'après on
peut vendre ce cheval et ça rapporte
encore un complément d'argent si on
arrête ça c'est assez fou disparaissent
et comme le dit très justement qu'est ce
que seraient les campagnes sans animaux
face en ce sens cochon sans rien de rien
il ya des liens affectifs entre
l'éleveur l'agriculteur qu'elle ait dit
ça va ça valait le petit veau qui l'a
aidé ben yahia moi je connais la culture
ils en voient pas leurs achats de
vêtements il enfants emmenés par un
collègue organise avait vu les photos de
yann arthus bertrand ou sur les cultures
ce rapport le contact qui entre
l'éleveur et sont les meufs magnifique
on sent qu'à une connivence qu' il ya
des liens c'est au service ingénierie
s'est divisée elle expliqué qui saura
vous faire souffrir les animaux mais ce
n'est pas positif de tous ces
groupuscules
la limite du fascisme encore une fois
c'est que on a un peu mis l'éclairage
sur certaines pratiques dans les deux
explosions a fallu mérites d'un seul
mérite de donner un coup d'éclairage en
bon ok ça c'est intolérable et les gens
sont plus sensibles à la souffrance
animale et ça tombe ça ce sont des
choses qui doit disparaître
ça c'est bien faut faire les choses bien
quoi mais ce qui intéresse aussi dans
l'agriculture c'est que vous ayez un
film là-dessus les gestes d'un éleveur
en france c'est les mêmes qu'un éleveur
en chine
ils ont les mêmes gestes et que les
animaux et quand il ya eu l'histoire de
la bête du gévaudan les yayi un livre
qui a été fait par jean claude bourret
il ya des témoignages de l'époque
montant à la baisse venant rappeler à
saint-louis casse tout ça c'est un
hybride entre les masses que c'est sûr
c'est un hybride anciennes guerres
financer quoi elle est surtout les
jeunes fermer les fermières puisque
justement en elle et tous les troupeaux
il ya des exemples de jeunes justement
qui ont été défendues par les animaux
les vaches les taureaux se sont mis au
travail
ce qui prouve bien le rapport qui a
entre l'éleveur et l'animal et il défend
les animaux en défendu le jeune le jeune
gable la fille qu'il est peu qu'il est
surveillé
puis ils ont protégé du loup chasowa ce
qui prouve bien qu'il ya un vrai rapport
de mai d'abord dans les temps lointains
les hommes et les femmes habitaient
vraiment à côté des animaux ça faisait
le soufflage et aussi donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très fort qui
remonte à très loin on peut pas arrêter
ça d'un seul coup c'est vraiment il ya
toute une économie derrière mais sur
supprime la vie de ces animaux et les
existences l'itc
c'est vrai qu'après il a posé pour le
manteau
en effet il faudra probablement manger
moins de viande qu'on a aujourd'hui j'ai
donc déjà on en mange un peu moins vous
semblez tellement génial que il ya 10
ans 15 ans mais enfin bon c'est vrai que
ça va poser aussi des pôles est-ce que
je suis bon nicolas sanhes voilà on
parle de cette société est divisée
peut-être des structures et peut-être en
tout cas en mutation est ce que ça
change le travail de l'artiste
hier j'écoutais jean claude carrière qui
travaillent c'est un scénariste mais lui
dit on peut pas écrire aujourd'hui
comment décrivez ya 20 ans il ya trente
ans l'environnement les choses comme ça
c'est des ces choses qui nous montrent
d'autres d'objets de tenir compte
est-ce que vous travaillez comme vous
travaillez quand vous avez commencé à
sculpter dans la question est complexe
parce qu'il ya plusieurs artistes
oui mais est-ce que c'est ce qu'on est
un peu on sait pas tout ce qui se passe
dans la société voilà mais pour répondre
des artistes qui se dégage du rapport au
réel
comment parce que je trouve qu'une rue
d'aragon au delà de ça de vie naturel
mais pour mai par rapport à mes débuts
oui ma pratique différente parce que
justement on a le rapport à l'image qui
est différent d'aujourd'hui qui en même
temps que je t'ai au mozart on parle de
peinture et parler d'art avec la
la référence déjà aux livres et non pas
à l'image à l'écran ce qui est différent
donc on n'a même plus de dix ans et la
peinture était l'art était ce un acte
purement plastique il pouvait y avoir
bien pas les insomnies c'est tout un
timing qui était négatif sur reims et
s'était donc engagée et pour la
sculpture et installation du tas de
choses voilà donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui
en plus c'est plus que c'est aussi comme
c'est aussi complexe dans l'idée de de
l'artiste comment il se situe dans la
ville de la société pardon il ya aussi
la pratique artistique de mme nécessite
des moyens en atelier du temps action
donc des choses assez changé et la
structure pensez forcément la vision des
artistes changent mais déroutant de
l'artiste que l'individu se répète mais
ce corps en couleurs qui se rend compte
d'une société où est ce que comme vous
disiez au fond il est un peu extérieur
ça il fait son oeuvre et il ya des
articles avant rapport il s'engage par
rapport sur des mouvements politiques
très content quoi contrarier d'un gris
toute oeuvre tous les mandats est une
politique c'est pas votre laissez pas
votre c'est pas votre sentiment au
brésil
le trail se produit il est je fais une
sculpture qu'il serait lui-même d'une
principes théoriques et s'inscrit dans
la durée dans le temps
voilà
équipant certaines choses de l'équilibré
de précarité même si sans que son coude
et pousserait là encore moment mon
travail
il est là pour dire expliquer où nous
dire ce que ce que ce que vous pensez
l'âge effectif je pense acheter
contrainte cheval des jeux mais en effet
je prends du recul et voilà sur chaque
feuille du bo de la beauté c'est pas mal
à nice le propre de la sofres et
contestés comme beaucoup d'artistes qui
disent dans le bo s'est brisé plus c'est
plus à nous de le dire moi je suis pas
l'auteur
vous avez ce qu'on va faire pour que
l'on sache de quoi d'un documentaire qui
vous a été consacrée qui est réalisé par
xavier gélin qui s'appelle achevé 11 une
oeuvre monumentale de nicolas sanhes on
va regarder la bande annonce de ce
documentaire comme ça on pourra
peut-être mieux en parler après donc
c'est un mort
[Musique]
la sculpture fera six mètres de long
quasiment six mètres de peau très
souvent méconnu vu 4 mai 50 heures dans
le cadre d'une aide et trois mètres
d'eau et repousser ses limites et c'est
aussi un mini durel celui du rêve ta la
personne et d'un personnel personnes qui
vont leur structure mais comment ça
tient qui voit là et cet innocent comme
ça deux gars t'es qui
qui est importante et c'est aussi le
lire non je me laisse pas dicter par la
matière ma sculpture ensuite une
sculpture de forme
c'est un propos formelle donc voilà je
dois amener la matière à mon attention
c'est pas le contraire
les limites il n'y a pas de limite mais
c'est là qu'en football tout blanc non
pas deux minutes
[Musique]
oui vous ne donnez pas de limite 1 16
comment considérer l'idée de strauss et
sculptures monumentales pardon comment
est née l'idée de ses sculptures
monumentales
ben justement c'est repousser les
limites de soi si le nom de la sculpture
chacun mais ça veut dire h c'est le par
rapport aux matériaux de h20 n'importe
matériaux décès la ville de valenciennes
le moniteur et 11 c'est l'année de
réalisation d'accord ok c'est plus clair
voilà ce que tu as et propose une
dizaine ips et faire des transformer
l'espace dans lequel on passait une
oeuvre chez renault du sens et de tonner
s'est à nouveau absent trop monumental
pour vous puissiez les déposer
subrepticement dans les villes
exactement
non non non mais parce qu'il ya un
artiste en ce moment dont le nom
m'échappe mais ça va me revenir sur man
qui m'aidait qui a commencé par mettre
un petit lac ans et à toulouse mais à
paris il ya bien une sorte de nains de
jardin ce serait très méchante et un
petit personnage en résine sur le pont à
côté la maison de la radio sur une pile
du pont et ses magnifiques parce que ça
ils dominent complètement de cette pile
de pont qui est toute blanche et il a ce
petit personnage comme les gens qui
tague sauf que là c'est mercenaries il
est très récemment il a installé une
statue de dom qui doit faire
à mettre 80 sur le socle de la statue
d'arago boulevard arago et statut qui
n'a pas de juste le soc depuis là depuis
la guerche que les allemands aient fait
fondre la statue d'aragon faut faire des
armes
enfin bon et donc ça n'a jamais été
remplacé et donc il a il a installé ce
statut mais il laisse à la nuit il la
dépose et puis voilà donc mais c'est
parce que c'est de la résine et qu'après
alors à toulouse il a fait ça et à
toulouse ils ont ils ont acheté faire la
mairie a acheté ses yeux pour les pour
les pérenniser
comment nous trouver oui oui parce que
ici il se cache pas c'est pas
honnêtement on peut tromper tout ça je
lui pas jolie est précédée c'est tout le
discours sur la gt dire ça ne se loupe
pas nombre d'interventions en fin de
partie
et pourquoi pas espérer sauver sa oui
mais vous ai toujours pensé de
travailler nos bourses et avec des
oeuvres assez monumentale et donc dans
l'espace public
vous avez fait des aveux gdf plus jeune
est ce que tu m'as tellement la peinture
pour l'attendre non mais la structure
c'est ce rapport au corps c'est moi
j'aime bien avoir ce rapport conflictuel
de ce trac ce rapport au travail mais
par exemple des multiples de de bogandé
jamais jamais je me cache une travée
sculpture la flamme direct d'accord je
sais pas de maquette
parce que gmail gmail vient se mettre en
danger
un travail qui est assez précis dans le
déroulement de méforme dans les bars à
son effort
du coup
je produis dans la chaîne home and tried
douvier et après j'assemble la sculpture
la nation'' travail d'artiste l'
intuition la envie de dire une pièce
commune et chardy à ces problèmes dès
qu'ils vendent espaces et qu'est ce que
vous pensez des tulipes jeff koons alors
à mais faut se mouiller moi je trouve et
ribéry
c'est vrai que ça va mieux là quel côté
du musée moderne je prends de la
commande là qui est autre chose qu'au
moins 500 une commande
c'est un cadeau après on est bien
obligés d'accepter un cadeau à trombine
oui mais ça se passe justement les
rapports avec la vous travaillez dans la
ville de trappes tellement comment
comment ça se décide c'est laisser des
commandes c'est vous qui démarre chez
bosch démarche je ne marche pas dans ce
sont des commandes mais la ville de
trappes a sauté réhabiliter la place
ovale pour lire au nom de la place et
beltrame
à nous d'être bridée il a demandé de
retravailler de réfléchir cet espace est
là en présidant une sculpture et en
donnant à cette place un nouveau usage
des gars et le trail des artistes il
épatera des architectes peintres et
dernis tel-aviv c'est une autre façon de
concevoir cet espace est la difficulté
était de pouvoir redonner à ce lieu
c'est une hausse au spatial est arrêté à
ses désirs est con de voirie occulter la
culture je vois bien marrer on n'a plus
de sensation de la dimension des choses
oui c'est de travail c'est de redonner
de la perspective de l'espace à d'une
ville pour que les gens
ce sont bien les réactions sur lesquels
s'est divisée où c'est plutôt favorable
ça c'est favorable j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de personnes qui vivent aux
trusts de la place qui sont heureuses
d'avoir un objet singulier puisque du
coup leur espace de vie singulier il
prend une autre dimension
puis de bronze est fier peut-être aussi
non d'avoir une oeuvre d'art oui vive
corps sexy ça rend la vie plus agréable
l'art imaginez je ne viens pas de
sculptures en square n'y a pas de
culture une statue scandale humain
encore à faire des phrases statues et
sculptures
donc voilà donc ça c'est un puits projet
une fiv un livre le jour d'une certaine
façon la nuit notre façon de la culture
blanche pour l'apprendre lumière donc en
avoir un programme et des allées il
songe avec les a et puis comme c'est
quand même un rapport aux 6,1 au nom de
sacrifice de connaître sommes donc il ya
tout un programme digital qui va venir
pas abandonner rappelé est de 7,6 en une
manière subtile
justement vous visiez l auteur sur des
oeuvres uniques
il ya une tendance dans la main
aujourd'hui qui est celle de la
justement avec des avec les moyens
modernes aux tapas et fuji je crois
qu'il est ca de reprendre la
reproduction et de la position exacte
alors ils sont en train de reproduire
par exemple le tableau de van gogh
alors on pourrait dire c'est un peu
bizarre est en réalité ils sont aperçus
que en les montrant comme ça multiplions
les d'abord peut déplacer des oeuvres
anciennes qu'on ne pouvait plus dépassés
ont donc on peut les voir
et en plus une fois que les gens ont vu
ses copines n'ont qu'une envie c'est de
voir les vraies mais dire que on amène
des gens à l'art aussi grâce à ça c'est
quelque chose qui vous vous comprenez
savoirs et démocratisation nommé mai
participent à cette démocratisation de
l'art puisqu'au fond vous êtes vos
sculptures elles sont à tout le monde je
veux dire que la sculpture c'est l'art
le plus débat au strict le plus
démocratique qui le prend le hall offre
à la ville
donc c'était tout le monde me dit rien
c'est pas tout le monde non ça reste la
prise de l'artiste et d'un produit de la
ville
mais oui tout le temps c'est là vous
êtes toujours mais mais mais
physiquement elles et à la mairie sur la
propriété intellectuelle importante
attendue par exemple des les architectes
mais même pour des artistes par exemple
y avait des histoires comme ça dans
artistes et les gens qui avaient acheté
1 9 hrs de lui qui l'avait pas mise dans
le bon sens il l'a reprise en disant
désolé si vous voulez vous dame n'était
pas comme il faut ces plus avoue quoi
c'est plus de sens de l'artiste
respecter le travail des artistes que
qu'il soit que ce soit des
commanditaires les doudous la propriété
intellectuelle qui m'intéressent qu'il
protège le trailer
là vous êtes basé ou actuellement à
trappes raf j'habite aux travaux et à te
lisant là-bas sans la balle j'ai
construit un atelier jeux de l'efs de la
place un peu ce que j'ai connu un creux
mathelier oui en effet oui il faut de la
place en affirmant et les commandes des
villes alors vous les valenciennes nous
y vais travailler dans le sud aussi bien
un rodez rodez rodez est une commande
qui est issu de
de l'inspection que jane smith est
d'obliger soulage janvier mais soulage
rodez il soulagé vous joins le noir et
le blanc mais là on aurait une grosse
pièce est plus importante que celle de
trappes au printemps qui prend mon qui
pris place dans un nouveau quartier qui
efface au mieux soulage
c'est important là dans la ville oui je
pense je prends l'exemple de bruxelles
qu'en ce bas à bruxelles ou à laisser
ses grands desseins de bande dessinée la
sur les façades je trouve ça porte
vraiment ça casse le pour les gens ça
fait rêver ça fait changer les idées en
cas c'était marrant parce qu'elle se
serait temps à regarder le début de
l'émission là on parlait d'une voix
entendues entre nous mais en vo club
là on parle d'art et on est un peu
apaisées c'est quand même pas mal non si
les pasdarans se permettre ce qui est
fait c'est une construite la relation au
travers des âges a justement parce qu'il
n'y a pas de problème avec l'un des
problèmes des questionnements en tout
cas avec la comptons pas nous parler
vous votez tout à l'heure voilà on vous
dit comme ça on a l'impression quand
même une certaine partie de l'art
contemporain c'est s'est évadé de la
beauté face et s'est éloigné de la
beauté de la recherche de la beauté non
le critère est ce quelque chose d'arc
d'artistes critères de la beauté c'est
subjectif mais chaque on dit qu'un
tableau l'on regarde le tableau est à
dire que lorsqu'on monte à bosser quand
un projet tant de soin des images vous
montre le tableau à plusieurs personnes
tout le monde parle différemment de ce
cadeau là je vais pas en commander
d'importance elle lie d'émotion que les
autres centres oui puis puis des images
leur littérature dans le futur parce
qu'il fallait
lescoules en une phrase est écrite 90 à
dos c'est pareil c'est à dire des formes
qui vous touche
des couleurs qui vous touchent leur
l'air de l'émotion servir de l'intuition
pour certains des oeuvres d'autres c'est
plutôt un message politique qui va être
pas chez donc en europe
j'étais en train vers quelque chose au
rapport au réel donc est ce que parce
qu'il ya quand même ça pose d'une
dispose comme c'est l'évolution de la
technologie des techniques ça change
forcément le travail de l'artiste nous
on continue à parler les pinceaux et
enfin d'ici quelques années plus de
raison qu'un jour on aura plus besoin
d'avoir les tableaux puis quand on sort
d'un virtuel où l'image est presque
revenue avec son musée soluséo n'avait
que s'amuser avec un casque avec le
musée avec des mordus
voilà vous dites voilà c'est pas
possible c'est un peu comme les gens
vont allumer le centre des choses ça
n'avait pas lu mais ressenti des choses
on l'a dans l'art ça ne remet pas dans
le centre de shanghai c'était vraiment
très malade mais quand même la
technologie des techniques
elle vous savent pour sculpter des
techniques nouvelles et matériaux nos
entrailles de la sieste vous n'avez pas
changé non je vais pas changer
j'ai travaillé informatique pour mettre
au point un vrai pour mettre peu ma
réflexion
non mais l'exercice n'est pas sans 3d
david haye ans j'ai rencontré son
travail très tôt il ya plus de vingt ans
que je travaille dans une entreprise
pour faire paris mais mes oeuvres et il
adopter en une forme son travail une
direction de son travail tout simplement
ce qu'on fait un scooter classique entre
où on allait quand on décroche un bloc
de marbre
sauf que là c'est la machine qui le fait
donc je vous avais facettes c'était
parfait c'est très joli donc il a
reconnu que sur l'estomac jeff koons si
l'espagne
offre qui fait non et des équipes des
équipes la sculpture relève de traits de
la mène l'industrie parlement des
façonnage et de l'artisanat et de
nouvelles technologies pour étudier
licence des oeuvres dont il faut pas
faire la part des choses pour dire parce
qu'il est le maître luis c'est une
direction sait pas bien où c'est bien
non il faut des outils connus comme quoi
sont autour de nous et profiter de ce
qu'il vous donne pour que votre création
aille plus loin la n est ce pas assez
amusante qui est lui à l'unesco il ya
quelques quelques jours c'était pendant
des collèges du patrimoine c'est d'un
photographe qui s'appelle stéphane simon
lacroix qui photographient des statuts
classiques par des statues anciennes des
statues grecques et bizarrement les
habiller avec un petit string
voilà on voit ça comme ça comme si le
sexe des statues antiques étaient des
choses qu'on ne pouvait plus voir
aujourd'hui la part donc encore une fois
on parlait au début de l'émission du
vivre ensemble je vais je rappelle quand
même que cette décision probablement la
plus grotesque été prise par quelqu'un
depuis dix ans de d'affubler ses statuts
de string de vichy ni grotesque a été
prise pour ne pas choquer des gens alors
bien évidemment dit pas qui c'est juste
mais voilà c'était pour préserver la le
regard de gens qui n'ont pas envie de
voir des hommes nus alors que le temps
plus d'intérêt que dans l'est dans les
statuts la cites les sections sont
ridiculement petits bars et des grecs je
crois que c'est elle était pâle elle
s'était sectionné mandat je sais que
c'est que c'est à l'unesco
leur secret
direction la bcc que toute la chaîne et
il n'y a pas un moment quelqu'un qui
sait dire on est chez les dingues là il
faut arrêter ça non ça du passé de
bureau en bureau et dia ba oui tiens
c'est vrai en voiture on va leur mettre
un string bah oui mais j'imagine même
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui a les meilleurs
qui va les acheter le stream un jour
qu'elle hésite elle ajouté illustration
c'est totalement ridicule quand il ya
des gens qui ont signé un bon j'imagine
propos un string pour une statue un
contact du jamais mais la statue ce
qu'elle est d'accord mais c'est ça vous
fait pas un peu ce genre de jeux pensait
pour faire le buzz faire parler de soi
un succès fou enfin pas sûr
hélas non la nation trois buteurs c'est
pas du tout pour faire le guet de vie
oui mais non cela dit ça on dit depuis
des années on a supprimé les cigarettes
dont sur le photo de sartre ou de de
gaulle d'ailleurs par yves de gaulle de
son genre grisaille qui lui avait déjà
été retiré lui est toujours là bas et
les solutions tableau promo de liberté
serait on va vers moi de liberté j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont pu se confronter
leurs deux noms non mais là je sais pas
comment je connais pas ce travail donc
je n'en mets
visiblement ça va paraître des pièces
faites par par 3d ou en 3d qui sont
hyper réalisme et la plus réaliste que
ça dans leurs contemporains il ya des
oeuvres qui sont vraiment bien sûr on
est hyper réaliste aujourd'hui encore
puisque ce que seul fils mais ça pose la
question de la de la transposition est à
dire qu on a fait quelque chose qui
relève du les sculptures sont à la
taille réelle
elles ne sont pas surdimensionner comme
dans la société grecque par exemple ne
sont pas le rapport à esthétique n'est
pas la même à quelque chose qui est à
dire commun si ce n'est que la position
vous dire quelque chose mais on n'a pas
se raser graisser le sujet s'est dépêché
de l'origine du monde au louvre parce
que non mais vous savez ça fait c'était
un débat c'est déjà une salle réservée
interdit de moins de 18 ans et c'est
pour aller la voir prendre pour les voir
ce tableau il est dans une petite salle
il faut avoir de fait majeur pour venus
voilà un beau lien c'est quand même un
gardien a cédé bonnaire qui surveillent
l'entrée donc c'est pas mais voilà mes
copains de l'exposition il ya
l'exposition de vinci et le succès
incroyable que ça peut avoir vous
comprenez ça vous avez envie d'y aller
vous et allez peut-être de sébum
c'est quand même mais c'est quand même
pas n'importe qui non c'est pas parce
qu'il y avait il ya des il ya des choses
mais c'est incroyable quand même le
succès de c2c détruit suisse qui étire
le cours de mandat c'est la beauté
alors moi je pense que non mais je ne
conteste pas ça mais je suis toujours
fasciné quand même quand il ya des
grandes expositions comme ça le le le
la foule ça le décalage entre ce que
j'ai produit aujourd'hui et ce qui est
aimé et apprécié un roux santé ars sur
moi je fais des oeuvres de fois pas je
vais pas revenir toujours non mais
laissez votre frère frank produit des
oeuvres et sont appréciés 3,83 là parce
qu'il faut que c'est par moment c'est la
seule autre ville
l'exposition qui a oui qui touchent le
public de public paie du grand public le
bail du public à dire parce que on est
toujours sur le dossier sur des oeuvres
qui sont encore là on parle de ça c'est
l'occasion pour la première fois que de
voir l'homme de vitruve qu'on a vu
pendant des années sur la pub manpower
et là et là enfin on sur le carreau
cassé
on va enfin voir le monsieur
et puis ça s'est passé comme ça nos
émissions d équité vinci code de vie
elle préfère quand ils font les parkings
l'invité était sava cyr c'est peut-être
vous avez alors des trésors tout c'est
peut-être aussi un point c'était avec le
succès de ces pays des expositions qui
sont évidemment de d'artistes reconnus
et depuis des siècles ça nous rase
peut-être qu'on ça nous rassure un peu
dans ce monde on en revient au score dès
le début
demande un peu se déverser à l'époque
c'est maculation époque de bien insister
par action bien sûr c'était pas
rassurant c'est mm et est même
extrêmement moderne enfants il va même
les voilà des éléments qui faisaient
comme ça qui était extrêmement seulement
les bas côtés il y avait évidemment on
va peut-être en mousse et la non dd il
ya un an
commencé le mouvement des gilet jaune et
oui ce sinistre anniversaire
alors voilà croyable des stations du
pouvoir il ya tellement de décalage
entre des gens très très riche des gens
très très peu ça s'agrandit de plus en
plus il faut il faut quand même raison
garder il ya quand même effectivement
rien de commun entre la situation au
chili succession en france alors à part
effectivement le fait qu'ils portaient
un gilet jaune éventuellement m'enfin je
vais refaire la moindre comparaison non
mais nous ne sommes pas là de la montée
des populismes qui est fait quand même
un phénomène important et la
contestation des pouvoirs quels qu'ils
soient qui est quand même inquiet quand
même dans le monde entier merci
infiniment à tant de la bernard de leur
don merci nicolas sale et donc on peut
voir aux heures où avant d'aller à
valenciennes c'est mieux c'est
magnifique
et puis je rappelle en chasse de just
can't scan aux éditions la joie dit dans
toutes les bonnes librairies
voilà donc le mec passionnant roman
voilà et puis à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de paf
merci à tous les trois
[Musique]